oh god are we gonna ask malik uh did you
hear about that republican
uh that died on the senate oh a news
report
oh yeah you gotta hear about that
yeah bro it's a republican right he died
of colvin 19
in north dakota now north recently
recently now he was again over in
october
show me this guy okay his name is his
name nah nah nah his name is uh or
what's his name david
i call it david a i can't pronounce his
last name 55 55
and corona you know north dakota their
cases are spiking basically he had a lot
of early votes
there you go right there oh weird not in
shape weird well he's a cattle he's a
cattle
uh he like what a cow he eats cattle
that man is not in shape and that's what
kova does
well well he died and he got he like he
was getting in early
votes now he wants he won the uh he
still won even though he died yeah he
still voted for him exactly a lot of
people
because he was getting so many early
votes in so a lot of people oh
he couldn't tell he can't [ __ ] him out
and i love what they do now so look now
they said okay look they didn't know he
was going to win so the republicans they
do the
patriots next man up kind of way but
then the guy was like
hold on we can't do that let's wait
until because this is the eighth
district
right of north korea in north dakota so
look so i was doing some research
right so i was like yo no one's one a
lot of people want to take that seat
now ask cat i was like do the democrats
decide you know like how you know when
you
shoot a free throw and a team get
injured and the other team got to pick
the uh
the player to shoot the free throw i
thought it was like that no the
democrats can't decide
no the republican republican but the guy
go to that article again
because i won't mess this up i want to
read this quote uh go down
uh where is he at right here what do we
have found in the most legal
lethal authority legal i couldn't see
i read my fingers let me just push it up
the general rule is the next person up
right that's we
went over that yeah right does not rise
up the legislative council
director joe john jordan
johnson whatever uh tribute at the time
this is all new we have an encounter
that that was so strange because i i
wonder what they do
you know what i'm saying like we we
haven't covered for the president right
the vice president steps up
like if let's say trump got when he got
covered passed away pence just steps
steps up that's what they do like
biden's going to die
any day now so you're voting for kamala
harris she's going to step up that's the
game plan by the way
what a weird time to start a job at 70.
but now
you say 70 he's 70 years old uh 78 sir
oh [ __ ] god damn i didn't know well well
that's that's the news is he 78 or 76
would that make him older or younger
than bernie sanders because bernie
sanders is about seven
between seven you might as well say
seven eight because his birthday oh 79
burning 79 doug and trump is 72.
trump looks so old last night so biden
came out was like we're winning
my grandma always said like hang in
there have faith
and then trump was like oh i got to get
on there because bert because
biden was like oh we won and trump's
like the hell you did so then he comes
out at the white house he's like
we're winning but dude he looks so tired
yeah he looks so tired just like three
in the morning
you know east coast they've been up all
night yeah it was like as far as this
election goes i feel like we already won
this already i was like damn trump you
know what you know what
you are strange and i get off politics
what's the election so suck my fat [ __ ]
um you know bernie sanders uh predicted
this
bernie goes because of the mail-in uh
ballads
it's gonna show trump winning early but
then when they count the mail-in it's
gonna go to biden
and then trump's gonna say oh that's
fraud and i'm not leaving the white
house and bernie sanders called it
months ago oh james because he was like
this is what's going to happen
yeah yeah jimmy fallon i saw that it was
you should can we can we play that jen
or no
it was friends huge huge video yeah yeah
it's only a minute and 30
and i was like damn bernie i like bernie
sanders
no no what yeah yeah no
it'd be on youtube though if you want to
see it
he's talking about here though right
right here that's trump that's true
bernie sanders election prediction jimmy
fallon goes viral word
word for word yeah that's pretty crazy i
think i mean paul thinks you know what
the [ __ ] is going on
they matched a video together no i don't
think it's not going to be the oh this
one's right
yeah and this is on twitter so we can
play it right
would and it's been said that we won't
know the results
until days later when do you think we'll
all right jimmy you raise an important
point and i hope the american people
understand it because
this is something i worry about my view
is called every vote must be counted
for reasons which i don't have the time
to get into tonight
you're gonna have a situation i suspect
in states like pennsylvania um michigan
uh wisconsin other states where
they are going to be receiving huge
amounts of mail-in ballots
unlike states like florida or vermont
they're not being able for bad reasons
to begin processing those ballots
until i don't know election day or maybe
when the polls close that means
you're gonna have states dealing with
perhaps millions
of mail-in ballots here is my worry
what polls show and what studies have
shown is that for whatever reason
democrats are more likely to use mail-in
ballots
republicans are more likely to walk into
polling booths
on election day it is likely that the
first
votes that will be counted will be those
people
who came in on election day which will
be republicans
exactly and here is the feel and i hope
everybody hears that
it could well be you know i don't know
what's going to happen nobody does
but it could well be that at 10 o'clock
on election night
trump is winning in michigan he's
winning in pennsylvania he's winning in
wisconsin yes
and he gets on the television he says
thank you americans
for reelecting me it's all over have a
good day
but then the next day and the day
following
all of those mail-in ballots start
getting counted
and it turns out that biden has won
those states at which point trump says
see i told you the whole thing was
fraudulent
i told you those mailing ballots were
crooked
and i got you know we're not going to
leave office
so that is a worry that i and a lot of
isn't that interesting
to a teen yeah we don't know what's
happening maybe the results will be on
our election day but
maybe trump saw this video should be
aware of yeah it's strange
you'll be a real savvy vet to call that
[ __ ] out yeah
the boy's been politics forever 78.79
forever since 1979 no no seven
years old oh he's 79 he was around when
what'd you call it guy got
jfk yeah yeah
i mean what else you got jim how about
that
when i get off stage in the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son